this week ubisoft released what is
already being called siege's deepest
most multifaceted operator ever azami
now i know a lot of you are reinstalling
to give her a try so i figured i'd give
you a very quick rundown as to how she
works the highlight of her kids are her
kiba barriers which are basically jet
knives that spawn mini circular sage
walls what's cool about these barriers
is that they can be used to block
anything they're also bulletproof so you
can use them to create ratty reliable
off angles but they can be destroyed
either with soft breech or three melee
hits there is basically no end to what
you can do with these things from
fortifying sights to screwing with
people's crosshair placement it really
feels as if a zombie is that think
outside the box breath of fresh air that
siege was in such desperate need of
just ran into sight
look at this look at this
so get out there start experimenting
with her gadget and let me know what
kind of crazy you come up with